pierre bonsoir renault vous êtes resté
silencieux pendant sept ans sept ans
c'est très long
que s'est-il passé pendant tout ce temps
le mal du siècle comme titre parfois
certains hebdomadaires la dépression je
suis j'étais en manque d'inspiration là
mais j'ai l'impression que la source
était à rick ma plume été asséchés
j'écrivais plus par dessus ça une
rupture conjugale une séparation un mal
de vivre
l'âge et l'alcool est au fond du trou
mais je suis un peu embarrassé de parler
de ma souffrance quand quand je viens
d'assister au spectacle du monde de sa
vraie souffrance la mienne est tout à
fait dérisoire tout à fait anecdotique
vous revenez de loin de très loin
comment vous avez remonter la pente vous
êtes allé voir un psy comme de man j'en
ai vu plusieurs mais un jour j'ai pas
trouvé le bon apparemment je pense que
la présence de mes copains et mes
proches ma famille était plus importante
que celle de 2 c j'irai pas de ces
escrocs mais ni de ces charlatans mais
j'ai pas trouvé la personne idéale à qui
parler
j'étais seul est plus de facilité mais
mes proches mes amis
finalement vous avez vécu quelque chose
de très banal la dépression beaucoup de
gens mais très singulier quand on la vit
oui quand ton avis et c'est grave mais
bon il faut relativiser il ya des vraies
souffrances humaines ya des frais misère
il ya des vrais malades il ya des vrais
des vrais des frais souffrance ça c'est
des problèmes de jeu les dire presque le
petit bourgeois quoi les privilégiés en
tout cas j'ai pas vécu sous les ponts
avec un fils de rouge de pire à vie ou
préfontaine j'étais dépressive dans une
belle brasserie parnassienne de
montparnasse avec eux entourés d'amis
comment s'est passé le déclic un moment
vous avez décidé de reprendre la main ce
soir j'ai écrit une chanson par hasard
par par des filles un copain j'avais
arrêté de boire j'étais en banque était
en période de sevrage un copain me dis
si tu m'écris une chanson je te paye à
boire j'ai pris ça comme un défi abc les
criminels mais bon
j'ai écrit la chanson et lendemain bon
j'ai pris ma petite moufles et derrière
lendemain quand j'ai relu la chanson je
me suis dit bas j'étais s'était
satisfait de mon travail j'ai pas fier
parce que j'ai la fierté c'est un beau
que je connais pas mais ai je pensé mais
une autre puis une troisième et puis
ainsi ses revenus et donc les croyances
ont été finis et s'est agit de les
enregistrer donc pour les enregistrer il
fallait que je retrouve un petit peu
mais mais mais piètre performance vocale
et pour ça il fallait que j'arrête de me
détruire
donc j'ai arrêté le tage et diminuer le
tabac j'ai arrêté l'alcool je suis
partie en studio voilà en tout cas c'est
un beau défi puisqu'il vous a sauvé oui
un petit peu oui
alors votre votre album s'appelle un
boucan d'enfer pourquoi un boucan
d'enfer votre enfer voilà mon enfer et
c'est par rapport à une chanson qui dit
kim je me permets de citer l'ami jacques
prévert en disant que reconnaît le
bonheur au bruit qu'il fait quand il
s'en va et que le mien de bonheur quand
il est parti ça fait un boucan d'enfer
que ça fait un bruit d'enfer et
finalement cet album qui est le plus
intimiste
c'est une forme de délivrance et une
résurrection
bah c'est un peu les deux c'est une
forme de thérapie de se livrer mais tous
les artistes sont un peu impudique et
moi j'ai toujours eu envie de chanter ce
que j'avais sur le coeur dans les tripes
et dans la tête est bon il se trouve que
cet album a plus amenés à parler moi
même que du monde extérieur que j'ai pu
le faire dans les albums précédents
mes chansons d'amour c'est les chansons
éternelles qui touche tout le monde qui
n'est jamais passée par là on vous sent
beaucoup un rebelle beaucoup moins
contestataire les champs sur ans les
deux chansons engagées c'est fini non
c'est pas fini de nous
il y aura toujours des motifs de colère
les d'indignation mais que j'essaierai
exprimé dans mes chansons mais sur cet
album là j'ai un peu c'est vrai le j'ai
eu une période où j'ai un peu baissé les
bras a rendu les armes mais nouvelle
génération qui arrive derrière moi pour
prendre la relève
merci beaucoup renault merci d'avoir été
sur le plateau de 19 20 et bonne chance
à vous